[Music]
I'm Christopher hi this week we're
talking about the importance of position
and how type position gives birth to
technique so one of the unfortunate
things about Aikido practices it's gone
on is we've become very technique
centric and by techniques I mean
actually the forms so we've gotten very
invested in the forms and and doing the
forms and we've begun to believe that
Aikido is the form so if we don't do the
forms then we're not doing Aikido but
that's clearly not true and it's true
from the founders perspective as well he
gave lectures saying that the techniques
aren't Aikido and that in fact Aikido
its highest level should be the
spontaneous eruption of techniques so so
doing a form does not mean doing Aikido
and so you know if you do Kota gosh that
doesn't mean you're doing the system of
Aikido I feel as a systematic approach
to conflict and that systematic
approaches independent of the forms
themselves now one of the big problems
with thinking that the forms are Aikido
is that thinking in order to do Aikido
to use your Aikido you need to get in
over to a position so you can do a
technique and so you begin to think that
the positions are the the children of
the the techniques of the technique of
the form so meaning I want to do this
form so that's when I go to this
position
but actually it's reversed and
understanding this reverse will do a lot
to improve your Aikido you need to
understand that the position is more
important than whatever comes off of the
position so the position is a tactic
it's higher up in the in the strategic
order of what we do then the technique
is itself so the technique helps us
facilitate the tactic which is this
position we've taken so this video is
going to be in and we're gonna do a few
here this week this video is going to be
about how the the position is more
important than the technique that we do
from it and how all the forms really
come because of positions that we find
ourselves in and not the other way
around
so I'm gonna get Josh out here and we're
gonna go through some of this stuff with
you Josh
all right so we're talking about
position in Aikido the first position we
have to understand in Aikido is the Hana
me position now understand the Hana me
position will naturally arise is my
desire to take care of myself
happen so I'm not getting into a hungry
position so that way I can do a
technique I don't want to do it taking
this guy cared less about that I just
don't want this guy doing anything to me
now force here in this position it's
called move Hana me in our school it
means without fun me so what's bad about
this position is if Josh and I were
trying to find out who the toughest guy
was right we're squared up to find that
out so meaning if I hit Josh I hit him
full force Josh hits me hits me full
force right until we trade it until we
find out who's tougher and I care it's a
foregone conclusion this guy's tougher
than me I know he's tougher he's faster
and that's why I need to use Aikido
stuff because he's a bigger stronger
beast than me so I need to be able to
take care of myself
so the first thing I want to do is to
bury my position okay so meaning I want
to get off to a slight angle now the
reason is because josh still is making
power most powerfully this way right so
he's best at making power here I'm not
there anymore
but Josh still is in my power zone so
because they came off here now I have a
slight power advantage Tim he's not
gonna stay there all day so understand
this is always going to be dynamic I'm
gonna move he's gonna move I'm gonna
move he's gonna move what the techniques
do is they help me maintain my positions
that's what they do as he tries to get
the new position then the techniques
help me keep that position that I have
so they're maintaining the position if I
come off to the side like this this puts
us in yaku upon me now that might be
really hard for you to see if I have
Josh lined up in a perfect calling me
and I'll end up in perfect on me now you
can see this is classic Aikido how we
practice right so real easy for
beginners to see what this position is
but that really just comes from moving
from a-squared position off to the side
right so Josh was running at me square
and I came off to the side like this
then that didn't what I'm doing here is
I'm coming off to that that yaku hanmi
position right so I'm gonna gaff cool on
me now if I stepped off this way this
puts us in I on me again it might be
hard to see but if Josh goes into a real
clear hanmi you can see we're in i Hani
stance and that just comes from me
stepping that way so when we're here I'm
gonna step over to the side in one of
two ways one of those ways is going to
lead me to Yahoo hanmi the other way is
gonna lead me to I've hugged me now
understand the second I do that Josh is
dynamically going to be trying to change
his position to improve it for him so
what happens there right so let's say I
move off into an eye on me like this so
I'm moving back here Josh is probably
going to start coming to my back side so
like this is pressing into that back
side now he has the eating me position
at the strong position for him so that's
what he wants meanwhile I would be
trying to press eating me on him so as
he's coming to my back I'm trying to
come to his back so we're always working
this back and forth back and forth back
and forth now how might that play out
really quickly well if we're moving
around so understand this is never gonna
be static you know Josh we're not gonna
meet like this on a field and then we're
gonna do some stuff that's not what
we're gonna do right this guy's coming
at me and I'm coming off to the side
like this or I'm trying to get out of
there and he's improving his position
now while that's happening in the
technique I'll show right now is showman
just it's really easy to go through
these as he's doing that I'm probably
gonna hit him so he's coming in and move
today I'm gonna hit him like this right
so bang my hands are gonna come up like
this to hit this guy because he's trying
to get to my backside so the first thing
I'm probably gonna do is some kind of
showman gyaku yokomen position like that
if he brings his hands up to protect
himself which is perfectly natural bang
we're gonna be here in this position
which is the shomenuchi position right
so now we have shomenuchi that's what we
have here so this is a classic position
now what's he gonna do from here it's
probably just start heading back here so
that's where he's trying to get is
trying to get back to that position so
what I do I try to remove myself from
that position now right here I used an
EQ to stop that from happening I caught
underneath the elbow and I'm driving it
now notice what this did it took my back
way away from him and I got into this
nice ETL position so Akio facilitates my
good position and not the other way
around a good position doesn't still
take Ethio I don't care about the EQ I
care about having a good position right
okay so we're here like this and he's
coming in now what if as we're doing
this I can't control him so he keeps
coming around I can't get Tom can't you
Tom can Tom's is pushing me up
another thing that happens here is song
queue so that's what song cue does it
immediately stops him from filling this
area if he walks into that area now bang
the sunk your sucks now we do have other
options so cinema some kids week I could
use triangle position to get back out of
there but what this might do is buy me a
few seconds when he's trying to fall
over here and just stop him for just a
brief moment now what's he likely to do
from here turn his back to me because
this hurts when he does that he gives me
the eating position so look he just
chose to give me the e DME position by
turning his back now if you think
supplying some fields the important
thing you think you just lost because
I'm not selling him very good right now
but instead of Southie oh I got the
better thing I got the heebie me
position the dominant position there
right so he chose to give that to me
because he didn't like the song cue so
the techniques and the forms facilitate
the position and not the other way
around all the Aikido techniques can
work out this way we could do it with me
feel we can do with song can we do with
all kinds of things because what I'm
doing is trying to get to a good
position no I don't care about doing the
technique I don't care about doing a
song cue I care about the good position
from the good position I'm again gonna
start to read distance once I'm
resistant then I'm winning right if I
can get way ahead of this guy and get
out of his ability to even know where I
am that's what I'd really like but
that's that's the progression I'm always
working towards so I don't want to get
close to someone so I can do a technique
who cares about doing EQ or something I
don't care about doing EQ ever to anyone
but Ethio can help me keep them from
hurting me which is what I really care
about I'm Chris Ryan is Josh teehee
Aikido Fresno thanks for watching
[Music]